the kind of person you want to marry
isn't something that everybody wants
it's something the value of which you
only discover on long-term familiarity
what you want is an air fryer girlfriend
or a Japanese toilet girlfriend not a
Corvette girlfriend you want something
which actually you know the value of
fully because over long-term exposure
they're actually technically called in
economics they're called experienced
Goods what's interesting about an
experienced good is that it's something
the value of which only becomes apparent
with use this is terrible using that
economic term to refer to relationships
it's not the worst thing people have
said about relationships on the internet